en el último vídeo presentamos la idea
de resistencias en paralelo estas dos
resistencias están en paralelo entre sí
porque comparten nodos y tienen el mismo
voltaje que pasa a través de ellas de
modo que la configuración se denomina
resistencias en paralelo también
mostramos que estas dos resistencias
podrían ser reemplazadas por una sola
resistencia etiquetamos esta resistencia
como r1 esta es r2 mostramos que podemos
reemplazar r1 y r2 por una resistencia
equivalente en paralelo erp con esta
expresión que voy a poner aquí para dos
resistencias 1 sobre rp es igual a 1
sobre r 1 más uno sobre r 2
así es como calculamos la resistencia
equivalente para dos resistencias en
paralelo ahora se pueden preguntar y es
bueno preguntar qué pasa si hay más
resistencias si hay más resistencias en
paralelo que pasa si tengo r3 y rn todo
conectado aquí que sucede con esta
expresión así como lo hicimos
anteriormente tenemos una corriente aquí
y sabemos que la corriente
regresa aquí la corriente se divide
cierta corriente baja a través de r1
otra pasa por r 2 y si tuviéramos más
resistencias otra va a través de r3
mientras que otra corriente va a través
de rn de modo que la corriente
básicamente baja por aquí y se divide
entre todas estas resistencias ahora
todas las resistencias comparten el
mismo voltaje aquí escribimos v todas
comparten la misma v y todas tienen una
corriente diferente suponiendo que todas
tienen un valor diferente para la
resistencia por lo que hacemos
exactamente el mismo análisis que
hicimos antes y sabemos que aquí y debe
ser igual a la suma este es el símbolo
de suma de todas las es y uno más y dos
más y tres más y n de todas las que
tenemos sabemos que esto es así y
también sabemos que la corriente en cada
resistencia individual y n es igual a 1
sobre esa resistencia x v&v tiene el
mismo valor para cada una de ellas por
lo que ahora sustituimos este
y aquí para ahí y vamos a obtener que la
general es igual al voltaje por esto va
a ser una gran expresión 1 sobre r uno
más uno sobre r dos más uno sobre r tres
más tantas resistencias como tengamos
uno sobre rn y hacemos lo mismo que
antes cuando dijimos que esta expresión
es equivalente a una resistencia en
paralelo vamos a hacer que sea igual a
una resistencia en paralelo por lo que
todo esto se convertirá en uno sobre erp
eso nos permite simplificar cualquier
número de resistencias en una única
resistencia en paralelo y lo escribiré
aquí así que para las resistencias
múltiples 1 sobre erp la resistencia en
paralelo equivalente es igual a 1 sobre
r uno más uno sobre r dos más punto
punto punto más uno sobre rm de modo que
esto les muestra cómo simplificar
cualquier número de resistencias en
paralelo en una resistencia en paralelo
equivalente nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo